my name is Jared Cohen I'm president of
Carnegie Mellon
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you to this wonderful event here today
Carnegie Mellon is honored to host this
summit on what I believe is one of the
most important of the many topics
Americans are thinking about in this
election year ensuring America's future
competitiveness in the global economy
America has been the world's economic
engine for more than a century largely
because of our commitment to innovation
based on new knowledge our bottom-up
creativity and a business and financial
infrastructure that supports the
creation of new enterprises there's no
better place to tell this story than
Pittsburgh where Andrew Carnegie once
changed the world with his new steel
mills we're still very proud to be home
to us steel but this city powered by new
ideas has transformed itself to lead in
some of the rising sectors of today and
tomorrow improved healthcare computing
with a purpose robotics that will change
the way we live and work sustainable
sources of energy smart infrastructure
an attractive efficient and green
buildings in every one of these areas
Carnegie Mellon Andrew Carnegie's
university along with the other superb
research universities of America is hard
at work at generating the new ideas that
will help to sustain the nation's
economic strength far into the future
our faculty and students here have
created some 200 new companies in the
Pittsburgh region which employ more than
9,000 people so holding this summit in
Pittsburgh makes great sense so too does
holding it at a major research
university doing so recognizes the
crucial role that education and research
have to play in America's economic
growth and competitiveness
renewing and reinventing historic
compact between America and its
university community that has been so
important to our nation's success must
be a priority as Americans face the
challenges and opportunities of a more
competitive world and the imperatives
for broadening pathways of opportunity
now I admit that I bring a particular
point of view to the issue of our
nation's competitiveness being a
university president other perspectives
on this complex topic will be well
represented by the distinguished panel
assembled here today brought together by
Barack Obama who was shown as
willingness confront the complexity and
high stakes associated with this issue
but I know Barack Obama also holds
education dear indeed his own life story
brilliantly reflects the power and
highest purpose of a university
education as the Gateway to achievement
and he has said that he wants to ensure
that every bright kid has the same shot
as he has had to make a difference
senator Obama has outlined a vision of a
higher education system in in the United
States that is both excellent and
affordable this is gratifying not only
for university presidents to hear but
also a profoundly hopeful message for
parents employers and most important for
every young American it's my pleasure to
welcome to Carnegie Mellon and the
Pittsburgh and be introduced to you
senator barack obama